3500 personnes atteintes du comique 19
sont actuellement hospitalisés dans les
services de soins critiques c'est là où
sont traités les cas les plus graves
pourtant face à la stratégie du
gouvernement certains se montrent très
critiques c'est le cas d'eric tricot il
est infirmier anesthésiste et
syndicaliste sud santé comment on peut
dans une même phrase dire qu'il faut
aérer les pièces toutes les 10 minutes
et forcer les gens à voir des masques
dans la rue voyez c c'est le non sens le
plus complet voilà ça ça fait partie de
ces incompréhensions
en tant que citoyen et en tant que
soignant que on a du mal à comprendre
fois que j'ai du mal à comprendre et on
a du mal à se projeter sur un futur
saint quoi c'était une maladie qui se
transmet maintenant qu'on connaît un
cheat au mieux keith hackett qui se
transmet de façon mal porté il faut le
lavage des mains il faut les gestes
barrière il faut effectivement à tour de
base dans des endroits clos mais et puis
c'est tout je veux dire y'a pas besoin
de d'avoir une seule stratégie tels que
le gouvernement l'objectif à savoir la
vaccination il faut qu'on aille sur
d'autres sur d'autres stratégies